hello there we are fast approaching the
midpoint of season 2 chapter 3 of
fortnite's forever growing saga the
battle for the island is hotting up and
the resistance are taking charge it's
time once again to go over the map
changes and the clues to the future
story of fortnite like midas's role in
io we'll get to that very soon i'm adam
this is my creator code let's do this
first to the rock family they may stand
like statues right now but they have
moved this week after a few years away
kid rock and his mama sharon stone are
finally embracing be honest when was the
last time you hugged your mum i'm not
judging and the dad dwayne has now freed
the rockville pup from the sand without
context this pose looks a bit like an
animal welfare issue but we all know
he's helping out little snoop dogg here
last update i asked you to predict the
future and many people said that they
think the rock family will build a new
home together let's find out what
happens in this story in about a
fortnight another update we are all
glued to is over by the impossible rock
for no reason at all a container was
added complete with a toilet chest
lovely then two weeks ago a second was
added and yep it happened again a shiny
new yellow container now sits high in
the sky we have three more updates this
season which could mean six containers
could be balancing somehow precariously
up here oh remember the two burnt out
cars near kony we looked at last update
for some reason there is now a third a
three-car pileup i am lost i have no
idea why this is here any fellow map
change experts got an opinion here
okay on to the story update this season
has been all about war between the might
of io and the ingenuity of the seven
we've been running so many errands for
the origin the imagined and agent jones
to a point where the resistance can now
win the fight seven days ago the first
of ios blimps was grounded by the
uprising the strange thing was it
crashed miles away in the ocean even
though it was tethered down
oh well and now this week the second
blimp has met its demise once again
somehow finding water both locations
still hold io chests if you need them
for a challenge and there's a siege
cannon to quickly rotate too the battle
has now moved to kony so keep on
fighting the strangest thing has
happened at each of these locations the
daily bugle and condo canyon the
defeated io flags have been replaced
like we expected but they were replaced
with ego this was a faction in chapter
two which was quickly replaced by ghost
and shadow a few months later back then
ego's design was actually a teaser to
the island being flipped because if we
rotate that logo around it becomes the
bunker we waited years to open which
eventually was another io facility
inside so here's my question why are the
flags back now what does it all mean if
you have a theory banging in the
comments and the best ones i'll read out
next time things are definitely about to
get interesting in this story and all we
need now is the return of midas oh oh
wait a sec
in one of the upcoming missions from
agent jones he says this this will not
come as a surprise but io management
loves doomsday machines loves them
there's even a doomsday division at hq
oh man their softball team is awful but
they will one day destroy us all so
kind of a wash have a very bad feeling
that we are not ready for what we're
gonna find out
did you hear that so much love to
uncover here first io officially have a
team dedicated to creating doomsday
devices my guess is that they make these
for realities that they visit and want
to destroy as quickly as possible so a
doomsday team would make sense sort of
it would also tie up to many of the
events we've lived through and one in
particular springs to mind we all dubbed
it the doomsday device all the way back
in season two chapter two the exact
season ghost and shadow overtook ego and
altar so that's another reference to
those flags earlier on back then midas
was revealed to be creating a device on
his floor in the agency which gave us
more questions than answers if i'm
honest most of us believe that midas
created this device to fight back the
storm's effects and escape the loop he
wanted out he likely did this in that
sealed suit we saw in one loading screen
at that point we didn't know if he was
part of the imagined order but now fast
forward a few years and that one line
from jonesy there's even a doomsday
division at hq could tell us that midas
was indeed a part of io and their
doomsday division and judging by the
level of skill and knowledge he had to
create that device suggests he's a
high-level member of io i personally
believe that he escaped the loop that
day and went into the dc universe just
like the foundation did and that would
explain why we have the midas rex skin i
may be getting a little over my head
here what do you think is the imagined
orders doomsday division a way to bring
midas back into the story cause i hope
so
back to map changes there are some more
to look at quickly remember the five io
drills which dug through the island and
eventually set up io outposts over the
last seven days two more have been
destroyed by the seven and the loopers
so that's three out of five gone like
usual the smoke in the sky marks where
the battle took place this leaves only
two locations remaining from when
sloane's first scout missions hit the
top side oh and whilst i was playing my
first game for some reason this one
didn't appear at all so i guess it's
going soon it will be interesting to see
what becomes of these swarmer
battlegrounds and speaking of smoke in
the sky look out for some near sleepy
sound take a walk down the road and
you'll see this somehow a vehicle has
lost control judging by those skid marks
go straight through a fence
and now he's marooned on the beach below
a crushed ice cream truck no less and
things get a little worse because look
who was driving pili i think you and i
may be to blame for this one because a
few weeks ago we were in charge of
teaching petey to drive and this is the
job we did totally our fault be sure to
talk to him because you can decide if
you make him feel good about himself or
absolutely hurried
you do you oh randomly clown berries are
back in fortnight the food group adored
by colombos have suddenly grown back and
wherever there are clone berries there
are combos so it looks like those beasts
are coming back sooner than later this
week we'll begin the unlocking of the
prowler which may or may not lead to
miles morales coming to the game
hopefully you know as prowler is his
uncle and all oh and by the time we meet
again star wars day will almost be here
may the 4th a storm trooper will soon be
on the island and will start to hype up
for season 3. in terms of law the
stormtroopers are here all thanks to the
imagined order listen to this the
imagined order has recruited the
galactic empire's finest soldiers to do
what they do best stay sharp aim true
and eliminate the rebel threat will
season 3 be a star wars crossover how
would you feel about that if we get an
obi-wan skin i'd love it anyway here's
some legends who kindly use my code this
week i'm adam you're awesome the next
time you see me for a fortnight video
should be a story recap i'll see you
soon peace
[Music]